-Welcome back to "Late Night,"
everybody.
Lately there has been an
important conversation happening
surrounding the role of nepotism
in the entertainment industry.
Well, this past week,
Twitter discovered
that one of my writers
is a nepo baby.
And I want to give him
the opportunity
to address the controversy,
so here he is -- Ben Warheit.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi. Hi.
Uh, so, I want to address
what people have been saying
about me.
First of all, I was never trying
to hide who my parents are.
I fully acknowledge
that my upbringing was
largely responsible
for my career success.
My father is David Warheit.
And my mother is
Christine Chastain Warheit.
-Wait. I'm sorry.
How are your parents famous?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
So, my mom was
the head librarian
at Christiana hospital
in Delaware.
And my dad was
a research scientist at DuPont
for 30 years.
So, yes, in many respects,
I started on third base
because of my famous parents.
[ Laughter ]
-Sorry. So, your dad was
some kind of scientist?
-Uh, [Chuckles] yeah, well,
he's one of the top 50 or 60
fiber toxicologists
on the East Coast.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, he' no Rick von Susani,
but he's up there.
[ Laughter ]
He knows him.
-I...
[ Laughter ]
I've never heard of him.
-Alright, well, you know.
You know, that's the thing about
nepotism, though, Seth.
It's not just
about name recognition.
There's a lot of other,
more subtle privileges
that come with
having famous parents.
-Okay, so,
what sort of privileges
did you get from them?
-Okay, well, for example,
when I was growing up,
sometimes my dad
would go to science conferences
in Europe.
And when he came home,
he would always bring me back
a Toblerone candy bar.
[ Laughter ]
Now, you couldn't get
one of those in Delaware.
[ Laughter ]
Not in Wilmington, not then.
Now, is that fair
to the other kids?
No, but it happened.
[ Laughter ]
And I'd be lying if I said
it didn't influence
how I got where I am today.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, and your mom,
she does what, again?
-She was the head librarian
at Christiana Hospital.
-So she was a librarian?
-Yeah, well, she was
the director of all libraries
at Delaware's biggest hospital.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
So, because she was
so important to doctors,
you benefited from getting
good medical care,
letters of recommendation,
stuff like that?
-Yeah. No. Um...
[ Laughter ]
But every time
I went with her to work,
I got to eat for free
in the hospital cafeteria,
and I could get
any soup I wanted
and bring it back to the library
and eat it.
Any soup they had.
Name, like, a soup. Any soup.
[ Laughter ]
-Now? You want me to name --
-Think of any soup.
-Split pea soup.
-If they had it.
[ Laughter ]
You know?
Any soup that they had.
-Mm-hmm.
-So, yeah.
I realized that hearing this...
[ Laughter ]
...it might make it harder
for people to root for me
and think of me as an Everyman.
But I just want to own up to it.
[ Laughter ]
-Ben, I don't think
you're a nepo baby.
-I am. It's okay.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
I think you just want your name
associated with
the nepo baby conversation
so you seem more important.
-[ Chuckles ]
Well, that's kind, Seth.
You're really being kind, but
I'm fully willing to accept,
you know, all responsibility
for my privileged position.
-Ben, the nepo baby conversation
is about people who benefited
from having famous people.
And frankly,
I just don't think
your parents are famous.
[ Laughter ]
-Really?
-Yeah.
It just sounds like
they're regular people.
-Regular people? Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Just run-of-the-mill, ordinary,
"nothing special about them"
kind of people?
-I mean, not to be rude,
but yeah, sort of.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. Okay.
That's interesting.
Maybe you would like
to tell them that
to their faces?
-What?
-Oh, my parents are here
at the show.
Hey, Mom and Dad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, hi.
Yeah, Seth --
Seth, wants to tell you
exactly what he thinks of you.
-No, I -- No, I don't.
-No, no, go on, tell my parents
you don't think they're special.
-Wait a minute!
-Yeah, no, that they're --
how did you put it,
"a dime a dozen"?
-I never said "a dime a dozen."
-Sure, no, no.
You just implied they're
a couple corn-fed simpletons
of poor breeding stock.
-I would not say that!
-Yeah, okay, go ahead, Seth,
tell my parents you think
they're as common as dog [Bleep]
on the sidewalk.
-Is that what you think
about us, Seth,
that we're as common as
dog [Bleep] on the sidewalk?
[ Laughter ]
-I don't think that.
-Well, why don't you
just let it out, Seth.
Tell my dad you think
he's a bad scientist
that nobody cares about.
-I'm not a bad scientist.
I know Rick von Susani.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I don't think
you're a bad scientist.
-Well, no.
You know what?
Then this is really messy, Seth,
'cause I'm having
a little bit of trouble
understanding
what exactly it is you do think.
-I think --
-No, no, no, yeah,
just tell my parents.
Look them right in the face
and tell them
what you think of them.
[ Laughter ]
-I think, they're famous.
-How famous?
-Really, really famous.
-Wow. Wow.
Hmm, so you probably
want their autograph.
-I do.
[ Laughter ]
I do want their autograph.
-Yeah, yeah, I figured.
You know...
[ Laughter and applause ]
These are, um -- These are
gonna be 50 bucks each for you.
And you know why
they're so expensive?
-Because they're very famous,
very special people.
-And what are the children of
very special, famous people
called?
-Nepo babies.
[ Laughter ]
-What was that?
-Nepo babies.
-A little louder
for the people at home?
-Nepo babies!
-Okay, so that would make me...
-A nepo baby.
-Okay, was that so hard?
[ Laughter ]
-I think we're
about out of time.
-Yeah, I'd say so.
-Give a round of applause
to Ben Warheit and
his very famous people --
famous parents, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night.